♪♪♪
- Today on "Sneak This,"
can't believe we got him.
Floyd the mailman.
[Bell dinging, applause]
♪♪♪
- Gentlemen.
- Have you seen anybody wear
the post office Air Force 1s?
- What? There's such a thing?
- Yeah, can we get—
- Yeah, throw 'em up right there.
- Can we throw 'em up?
- You might not be aware of
this, but in the sneaker world,
you're basically Santa Claus.
[Sound of water running]
- Oh yeah, man.
I've thought I've been Santa
Claus for a long time now,
to be honest with you.
The guy's coming to your door, man.
Leave me a plate of cookies, you know?
- What kind of shoes
do you wear as a mailman?
- Uh, the New Balance.
[Crowd reaction sound]
They have a work series, like a 626.
- When you see our house, are there any
signs that a sneakerhead lives there?
- Sure.
You know, you see the same—those boxes
constantly coming like that, come in and out.
I mean, I pretty much can tell
what's coming through and what's
coming into the mail. Some of those
boxes with the black bags,
you know there's a magazine in there.
There's only one magazine
they deliver in a black bag.
[Whispering:] Pornography.
- Whenever you're shipping a pair of
sneakers, they always ask you,
how much do you want to insure these for?
So that's why we're playing the game
"How much would you [bell dings]
insure these sneakers for?" [bell dings]
- I wouldn't pay more than $120 for those.
- How much are these? $25,000?
[Buzzer]
- [Laughing] Get out.
Are you serious?
- Yeah.
- That's not the same shoe?
- It's definitely different.
- How much you insuring these for?
- Two and a quarter.
- Two and a quarter?
- Two hundred and twenty five.
- Dollars.
- These are going for like $8,000.
[Buzzer]
- OK, uh, $450?
- Times three.
[Buzzer]
- $2,250.
- Like $12K.
[Buzzer]
- $375.
- $20,000.
[Buzzer]
- The New Balance is one of
my favorite brands. They're always
reasonably priced for the working man.
I'd say $295.
- Pretty reasonable. These are $450.
[Crowd reaction sound]
Finally, if you could give one piece of
advice for the sneakerheads out there
in the world, what would you tell them?
- Get to know your mailman
- Fucker!
- Get to know your mailman, kids.
♪♪♪